hey everybody my name is melisha
mcgregor
and i'm a senior software engineer slash
developer advocate at conducto where we
make
ci cd tools using python instead of yaml
but today i'm going to talk to you about
making vr way more interesting with
javascript and brain.js
so at the beginning of all of my talks
especially
this year since we're virtual i know
everybody kind of zones in and out
so i like to give a quick overview of
what we're going to be talking about so
you know when to focus
and when you can go get food or whatever
we'll start with just a background on vr
then we'll get into actually making a vr
app and making a vr app i'm going to
attempt to show you some code
that i'm not going to change because it
worked
a few minutes before this talk so i'm
hopeful it still works when i try it in
a few
then after that we'll talk about some
background on machine learning
we'll add machine learning to the vr app
which i hope you guys will find really
cool and
we'll go over a few other considerations
and finally wrap up with just some key
takeaways
so to jump right into it let's talk
about some background on
vr it's relatively new in tech
so there's not a lot of you know
tooling around it there's not a lot of
hardware around it even though it is
being developed and it's starting to
pick up speed
is just super new and there are a lot of
people working to make it more
accessible
and easier to get started with as a
developer
and as a user so
these applications that are currently
being made with vr
include things like training med
students
video games of course other forms of
entertainment like us all eventually
entering the matrix without
knowing it or maybe we'll just willingly
go
anyways these are the current
applications or some of the things that
are being done with vr
and something that's kind of helped
with gaining traction in vr is that it's
offered a lot of different career paths
for developers
so you don't necessarily have to make a
web-based app
to do a vr project and you can take the
skills you have from web development and
use them in vr
which opens things like using
virtual reality in a browser
maybe even expanding to different fields
like
we'll have vr agriculture apps
i don't know somebody's going to make it
one day and it'll be super useful and
cool but
that's just another career path that we
can take as developers
and as the hardware keeps improving as
oculus makes more refined versions as
google starts well continues to work on
whatever their fancy top secret vr tech
is
what when these hardware um
these hardware pieces start to get
better
and they give more people access
to vr headsets that's where we're going
to see
kind of this boom in vr so
we'll expand away from just video games
and entertainment
when the hardware is so cheap that you
could
furnish an entire school with them or
maybe you could use them for
i don't know some other kind of training
either way it goes as the hardware
improves we get to do cooler stuff with
the software so
that's one of the things we're waiting
on for vr to really
start i guess embedding itself
more into what we do
so with that background out of the way
we're going to go into some live
code and see if it works
i have confidence and hope that my code
is good
which usually famous last words right
but i'm gonna attempt to at least just
walk you through what's happening
with this vr app and i'm going to go
ahead and start it
because we know how long it can take to
start an app locally
they didn't this time that's fine let me
open it in the browser
just to make sure
let me open a new browser just
so we have something clean for
the vr world so
this one should be localhost 8080.
oh it's loading i'm not going to show
you yet though because you need to know
how the code works first
so i'm using the a-frame library
and it's one of the more popular
vr libraries in javascript so as long as
you know
some html and some javascript you can
make a vr
app literally right now so you'll
import the a-frame library like this
and just to make it easier to get
started
with vr you know you have to have
different assets in the world
you have to have a world for the assets
and if you're not super big into
computer graphics
and just different kinds of design
then it's really hard to make all of
those things
that's a whole different coding problem
if you're familiar with something like
blender it is beautiful for making
assets for vr applications or
basically any web-based thing where you
need
a 3d model but i digress
to avoid having to make our own assets
and environments
you can import this a-frame environment
component
library package thing and it comes with
a bunch of
pre-made environments that you can use
to give your world a base layout
and then you see here we have two custom
scripts that we'll go over in a little
bit
but this is the basics of what you need
to import to get started
so where it gets interesting is here in
the body
a-frame takes advantage of these a tags
so it's really similar to java's not
javascript to html
but it's been a-framized
and the way it works is inside of your
body
you have this scene component and as you
can see
the scene encompasses everything in your
vr world
so that is how a frame knows hey
i need to make sure i'm rendering this
in the browser correctly
the first thing you do inside of a scene
is import your assets
so in our case we're gonna have a few
images
and some audio that i really would like
to play but
for virtual conferences you probably
don't want to hear video game music
in the background for the rest of the
talk so i just included this in here
in case you want to add some audio to
your vr world
you have a really easy way to is just
the audio tag
it's nice right but again i digress
we have our assets in here they have
these ids and we're importing them from
whatever directory they're in so we have
assets
then we have some primitives in a frame
so this a box
is literally a box so you have
an idea of wooden blocks so we can
target it with our javascript
it has a height of 3 meters
because well the si
unit system is better again i digress
it's three meters though
and the rotation on it is just arbitrary
but that's the
x y and z axis and we gave this one
a source for what we want it to look
like
so we're giving this block a wooden
texture
which means we're basically
imprinting this image onto this
box that's all and we give it a position
in the world which these units are
also in meters which is wonderful but
it is 37 meters away from the origin
in the positive x 1 meter
above the origin in the y
and 37 meters behind the origin in the z
so that's how locations and sizes and
things like that work then here we have
this
attribute that gives it an animation
that just happens in place on a loop
we take the property of the object that
we
want to move about so in this case we
want the box to move on the y-axis
and we're going to take it from its
initial position of 1 meter
and raise it up to 2.2 meters
no particular reason it was a good
number at the time
but after that we're going to say
hey alternate directions when this meets
2.2 meters make sure it starts going
back down to 1 meter
and this whole animation takes two
seconds and we just continuously loop it
that's how you do some of the animations
in here
and then we have our own attributes this
is where it gets
fun so we're not going to jump into that
yet because we gotta finish up here but
it is right after this so now that you
know
how a primitive works and you've seen
basically the core attributes you'll be
working with
we can go ahead and finish this up so we
have a sphere
and it has that metal texture from the
assets up here
and we have another box it has a
different
attribute on there i want you to make
sure you remember this one it'll be
important in a little bit
but we have a box we have a stone
cylinder
and then we have a plane with the
instructions for the game
so when you enter the vr world there's
just this plane
floating in the air telling you you need
to find these four
objects that are scattered about so
that's how we do that it's just a plane
inside here this
is the base a-frame entity
you can make up any of these other
primitives with just this
a entity tag you just have to set all of
the attributes
and then down here is where it gets kind
of into the nitty gritty of how the
world works
so you need some kind of environment
unless you want your users to
float around in just this big open
white empty space or you can give them a
sky
and a ground and some trees to run
around in or whatever else you want
so in our case we're using the entity
tag
to set the environment for the world and
this is just a bunch of attributes that
are being set
the reason we can do that is
if you remember earlier we imported this
package
that gives us access to pre-made
environments
so that's how we're working with
this environment attribute we're just
setting the different values
to use for that world so we have our
environment
and the last thing we need is the camera
and how we're going to tell the user
where they're looking
on the screen so we have another entity
we have a camera this just a camera
you put the looks controls on it so
that's how you can
use the hand controls and it can pick up
your head movements
or on the browser it can pick up your
keyboard movements
so we have our camera and inside of the
camera
we have this little cursor entity
this is just a little black ring in the
middle of the screen
that lets the user know where in the
world they're looking
so it helps with targeting objects
when you're trying to click on them as
you'll see pretty soon
but this is how you make up a vr world
this this is it if you know some html
you know a little javascript
and you don't mind reading through
documentation you can have this exact
same app done
in probably the next couple of hours
but now that you've seen the code i can
finally show you the world
oh see this is that
oh let me click it this is the entity i
was telling you about
where we have our list the fact that i
can use the mouse
to move around and look is a part of the
looks control attribute on the camera
and this is in the browser so you can
port
the same code over to any of the popular
headsets
i think oculus is the one that's
commonly used with a-frame but
we're going to try to find something i
usually can find it pretty fast
but maybe i don't know where it is today
oh there's the metal sphere you see how
that
little black circle helps because if i
didn't have that i wouldn't know which
direction i was really looking in
but if we drag that over here
we found an object and if you go back to
the home base you'll see it
right here so yeah this is the gist of
the world you run around and you find
stuff but back in the code i want to
show you how that happened
so remember that found item attribute
that's a custom script we made so that
whenever we find one of these objects
a-frame uses this register component
to interact with everything that's on
the screen
so we go ahead and find
the objects that we want we set an
event listener to them and inside of the
event listener
we're adding just this position so
anything that you want to happen
on the object when it's found you can
set it in this
ad event listener and in our case as you
find each item
it just makes a row of items that you
can walk through at the end
and that is it for the
vr portion of it everything this app
does right now
is just from these two files that's all
but now we can get back into
some background on machine learning so
when we add it to the app
we're not like what is what is this
so we'll be using a neural network
and a neural network is just this set of
algorithms or
one algorithm that can be used to make
predictions
based on data that you've given it
so it's made up of a layer of nodes
because it's supposed to represent
what it's like inside of your brain so
we know we have neurons that fire off
in neural networks there are different
nodes that send
different information further through
the network
and this is what a typical node looks
like
so you have some inputs these are
usually referred to as
features and they reflect what is
important to the prediction you're
trying to make
so in our case we're going to try
and predict where we should place
objects to increase the likelihood of a
user finishing the game
so that might mean we want to look at
how many steps a user's taking
we want to look at if they found an
object or not yet
and then you can use the weights to
determine how much that affects the
overall prediction
so you're not just speeding your data
and it spits out a prediction you're
feeding in data
that specifically gets tuned
to show the effect that your inputs
actually have on your output then in
here we just do a bunch of cool math
and we get our prediction but
usually there's more than one
layer of node nodes and when that
happens
you're already doing deep learning deep
learning just means you have
more than one of these nodes in a neural
network
that is all so hopefully that
gives a little bit more perspective on
what's happening in the machine learning
world
is not as terrifying as a lot of people
make it out to be
yes there's a lot of math but when
you're a developer
and you're not developing algorithms
you can just use the tools in the
libraries to do all the math for you
as long as you get the basic idea of
what's happening
that's all you need but we're getting to
talk about
my personal favorite javascript machine
learning library
brain js so there are a lot
of reasons i chose this over tensorflow
a lot of reasons but
one of them is because it's easier to
use
if you know how to work with objects
arrays and arrays of objects
you can do machine learning with
brain.js
you don't need to learn what a tensor is
you
it doesn't hurt to know about
dimensionality because you need to
sometimes but there's just so much it
strips
out from the math heavy part of machine
learning to let you focus on
implementation so you don't need to
know what stoichastic systems are
you don't need to worry about
bayesian distributions and
yeah flashbacks to math stuff but you
don't have to worry about all of that
you can just jump into the library with
whatever idea you're trying to test out
and test it
and then the tutorials are super easy to
follow they're straight to the point
and by the time you finish them you know
how to use the library
you might not know exactly what is
happening
in the machine learning portion but you
know how to apply it if that makes sense
so with machine learning projects there
are a few things you have to consider
especially when you're choosing the
features that you're going to use for
the inputs for your neural network
so the first thing you should think
about
what is going to add the most value for
a user
we usually get caught up in how cool
certain tech things are or this new
shiny tool
or whatever obscure tech thing we've
heard of we get caught up in that and
forget about the user
so when you're choosing features you
probably already want to know
what you're trying to predict that's
going to help you figure out
what's adding the most value for a user
and then how are you going to get the
information you need to train that model
so are you going to go buy data are you
going to collect data from users somehow
are you going to start with just some
dummy data from a lab you need to know
where you're getting this information
from
and again what are you trying to predict
with
all of this data and information you
have there are companies that have
literal terabytes of data hundreds of
terabytes of data
and they're like yes we're going to do
machine learning with this
but they have no idea what they're
trying to find out and that takes away
from the whole purpose of machine
learning
what are you trying to find out with
that data
and this is one of my favorite questions
if you make this
update if you choose this feature
will the user care will that feature
choice you made actually influence the
prediction
in a way the user will care so
as much as we like to do cool new stuff
it's important that the people we're
making these tools and apps for
care about the changes
and now here's time for another moment
of truth
to see if the code will run
so we've already covered how to make
this
the thing that i want to talk about next
is the
actual brain.js code
so we have this little note server set
up
we're importing the brain.js library
and just some of the other libraries
that go with the
backend node app like body parser
expressing course
so we go ahead and set up the app we're
using these
different methods to handle
our data and interactions with the front
end
and then we get to the really
interesting part
so i do have this code in a github repo
and i'll post a link to it in the
thunder play slack
after this talk in case you want to look
at it
it's it's got some comments in here so
you can read around
but the first thing we're going to do
for the machine learning model
is set up our training data
and the way brain js works i mentioned
it just
basically works with arrays of objects
so our training data we've decided
the features we're going to use to
predict
where we should place objects next we've
decided we're going to take
the position of the user
so the x y and z position of where they
currently are in the world
we're going to assign a value based on
whether they found an item or not
and we're going to look at how many
virtual reality steps they've taken
to maybe determine if they've been
wandering around for a while
and they're a little lost so this is
what our
training data input looks like our
training input data
these are the features that we think
will predict
whether or not a user will finish the
game
so to make that prediction with
something like a neural network
you have to have both the initial data
and that includes what your predicted
values would be
this is called a supervised machine
learning problem because
you have to train the model with input
data that's
associated with output data that's
already
been proven to be correct
so basically what that means is we have
input data we have predicted data and
we're just trying to figure out
how those two match up mathematically
so think of what was it y
equals ax plus b sum about slopes and
whatnot
but that's pretty much what we're doing
we're solving for
the function instead of the values
but you've seen what the input data
looks like we have
quite a few array objects
now we're going to look at what the
initial prediction data or the initial
output data looks like it's also just an
array of objects
but it predicts whether or not
a user will finish the game based
on all of these features so that's what
we're trying to predict here is whether
or not they'll finish the game
and based on whatever values are up here
they will finish or they won't finish
it's just another array of objects
so now that you know what the input data
looks like you've seen what the output
data looks like
we're going to combine all of this into
one
array of objects where we have our
input data as a property
and we have our output data as a
property
so all that happened here it's like i
said we made
a an object
with our training data and we did that
because
that is how brain creates neural
networks
which we're doing right here so this one
line of code
makes an entire neural network with
three hidden layers
and the hidden layers represent how many
nodes we have in this neural network
but we just call this new class
we give it the parameters it needs
and it gives us a neural network
and then we want to go ahead and train
this network
i'm going to save this and hope that a
space
doesn't break the code because we know
that happens sometimes
but we go ahead and train the neural
network that we just made
with this object and we're
giving it that training set data that we
made up here
and that's it we have a trained neural
network now
it's ready to make predictions and we
can use it
in our vr world but
a lot of times with machine learning
projects
pretty much every time with machine
learning projects you want to
take note of the stats on the training
process
so you want to make sure that you have a
low error
you want to make sure that it doesn't
take too long to train
i've tried training some machine
learning models that have
bricked computers not crash them but
blue screen of death because i didn't
have the right resources
so you really want to make sure that
your model is
performant before you run too big of a
training thing
so a lot of times we'll run a s
like a test training and then
we'll run the real one with all of the
data once we see how
performance is how error rates are and
things like that
but just to get an idea of how we use
this model after it's trained
we go ahead and log a little bit to the
console
and this net dot run that
is how you get a predicted value with
new input data based on your model
so in this case we're passing in a new
object that has a user's xyz
position they haven't found an item and
they've taken
over 3 000 vr steps so the likelihood of
them finishing the game is
probably really really low
but now that we've gotten that out of
the way we've trained our model
we've run it we've checked the stats on
it
so we'll go ahead and just make an api
endpoint that the front end can post to
and take advantage of this model
so what we're doing here is we're just
checking
out the positions the steps and whether
they found an
item and that's passed to us from the
front end in the request
then we're gonna get that value
and we're just making something up here
so we're going to use the model
this is the part that i'm attempting to
live code
we're going to make a new variable
and call it a
prediction yeah prediction because i'm
super creative
so we'll call it prediction and we'll
take our model
and do dot net run and
then i'm just going to copy and paste
this
in and give it the appropriate
properties
so they'll be x y
and i could leave it like that but i
like to
explicitly define object properties
because sometimes later on
it can i don't know it it throws me off
occasionally
but anyways so we're giving this to our
um our neural network and we're going to
take the prediction
which is whether or not they will finish
the game
and instead of item found which was just
a placeholder
we're going to put that prediction so
we're going to say
if our prediction that they will finish
the game
is greater than 50
we're going to move the objects
further away from them that way it makes
them stay in the game longer
and they explore the world more but
if they're having a hard time and
they're not likely to finish the game
we're going to move objects closer to
them
so that they'll find something and it'll
keep them engaged
and they'll keep playing the game and
exploring the world
so we take the prediction we pass
these new positions back and that is how
we relocate
the objects in the world using machine
learning
this is how you make a super custom game
to any individual it's based completely
on their movements their actions and how
they interact with the world
and of course this applies to way more
than just
games we could use this i don't know why
i want to do vr in agriculture but maybe
one day
but anyways so we can take a user's
real time actions and
make predictions to update things real
time
we don't have to retrain the model we
don't have to
handle a bunch of like back-end requests
unless you want to
but this is the entire machine learning
model the training and the
implementation of
machine learning in a vr app
but yeah yeah we go ahead and
send our status we send the data back
and
start up the server so
let me see if i do a split terminal
and just run this
back in so
yes let's see
how training did so our error
rate isn't the best it's a 25
error rate so this is an example of when
you would probably want to get
more data or you'd want to look at your
features to see if you can do any
grooming there
but you generally don't want a
25 error margin you want to make sure
that
the inputs you give your model
accurately predict that output or else
you end up with
not what you wanted and you see it took
20 000 iterations but that happened
really fast
because look at the data we're using
it's not that big
data for machine learning projects can
take
up gigabytes so this this is nothing for
it
but it did predict a likelihood of about
51
finishing for this data
we inputted so this is just an example
of what it looks like
when you get your predictive value
so i'll go ahead and do that and i want
to show you
where this works so there is no
particular reason
i put this attribute on
this element other than it's just the
one that i picked first
but what this does is whenever a user
finds
this blue box it's going to
call this so we're going to
find all of the objects in the world
we're going to
get the position from the user
and that includes like the steps and
need to go ahead and include some other
stuff
but that's in a different file so we'll
go ahead and send the position back
and once we get the response we set the
positions for the objects
to whatever that new position is based
on whether a user will finish or not
so this send user data it's coming from
this user model file
and that's why we're not setting the
steps or
item found in the cursor listener
because this is how i set it up for the
demo
but we're using axios to go ahead and
make the post request
we have the user's real positioning
we made up something for some steps and
just for the sake of things we set this
attribute to true
but the way it works we go ahead and
make that call to that
endpoint we set up and it's going to
return our data
and that's how we get these so
that is how we implement machine
learning in a vr
app to make stuff more interesting more
custom
for a user
so back here we can go ahead and start
binding down
a few other things you should consider
when you're working with
vr or you're making some kind of machine
learning model
is the overall user experience
what kind of impact are your decisions
having
on the experience you're trying to
create
so every user has different expectations
for how apps should work
and you have expectations for how users
should interact with it so when you're
making a vr app consider
how they're moving around the world how
they'll interact with things
and whenever you're working on a machine
learning project
make sure you're using data ethically
this is something that is a very gray
area
in tech sometimes is the ethical use of
data
so yes ads are very lucrative
at the moment but is that really
something you want to
steal data from users vr worlds and
sell to people just just keep your data
everybody will appreciate it a little
bit more
and then i want to go ahead and break
this common
misconception there is no best algorithm
in machine learning
it's not one it depends on
what you're trying to predict it depends
on the data you have it depends on the
resources you have
it depends on maybe even the team you're
working with
so there is no one machine learning
algorithm that's the best
it super depends on what you have to
work with
and if you're interested in more machine
learning things
definitely get into python because
javascript is great i love javascript
and all of its
wonky jankiness but python has
way more um
way more packages and libraries for
different machine learning applications
they have some really specific ones like
bert which is how you train
a natural language processing model
so if you want to get more into machine
learning
definitely look into the python packages
so now just about to wrap it up a few
things i hope you remember from this
is that it's so important to combine
multiple
areas of tech we usually stay so siloed
that
web developers are different from
i don't know security people who are
different from
devops people even though we kind of all
use
really really similar tools even if
the underlying languages or tech is
different
or even the way applications are created
we all use these different areas so it's
okay
just mush them together and see what
happens
and please remember that ethics
i mean ethics around data is important
but ethics in general
especially in tech they're so important
because
if we don't pay attention to those
really small things
it snowballs to become something giant
like skynet or
some other entity that's just going to
take us all out one day
because this is 20 20.
and try new stuff so i picked up the
a-frame
library one day last year and just made
little apps and got some projects
with it so don't be afraid to try new
things
there's also a react version of
um a vr implementation i think it's
called
react 360. i'm not sure if that repo is
still being actively maintained though
and if you take the time to learn
something
that is interesting to you and it solves
the problem you have
you you win you did it this is what we
want
we want to combine things that have
useful outcomes even if it's something
small for just
around the house so that's all i have to
share with you today
and if you have any questions um
definitely around
be checking the thunder playing slack
and of course please follow me on
twitter at flippedcoding